hey Tommy
oh hi gray we're gonna watch a video
today of you in a bunch of you know of
our favorite disaster movies from screen
junkies we watch the video we spray our
self don't hurt anyone okay
but before we do that Tommy can you tell
them what what are what the website is
that's a shout-out great I tell them
what is it your views dot-com is a new
social platform that turns how well you
like movie based on your tastes and
films and films you review on the
website I've also heard that of your
reviews helps you to connect with people
who share your passion and taste for
movies haha that's right gray you think
of you like personal Ron tomato tailored
to your and your friends specific
cinematic tastes matter of fact Tommy my
friend John and I we just started using
viewer reviews and matches are pretty
spot-on
I love Johnny's Greg guy as grant pinion
about movie he loved my movie he see the
room 200 yeah and this also really easy
to get started gray once you have in the
Cal you fill out a couple basic
questionnaire to give this size stands
for your specific taste and from there
you're ready to start reviewing movies
share your taste and connecting with
people so what should they do Tommy oh
you watch you do you got to the
discretion box you hit that link you
check out viewer reviews calm today they
follow the real rejects express yourself
hit the follow button to read all our
review we got writing reviews up on the
viewer reviews now express myself
through through words Greg I use
Warren's Greg I hit this bill for you to
show the world that he is the literal
disaster artist
[Music]
go faster
[Music]
[Music]
that's it yes Mary Jo I'm sorry I call
you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't involve by Jewish community come
on God
[Music]
y'see brutalizer
sure start hey I'm your president thank
you for coming and you've been selected
to go to Mars - how the space your
courage is inspiration as well as you
know yes will you go to space because we
want you to be someone else
no dinosaurs know more about dinosaurs
does not exist but your courage give us
I know you have great preparations like
luck to you and while fuss is with us
and you are with us as well so good luck
have a nice trip soon as a pasta girl
thank you
[Music]
thanks to Tommy for coming and
celebrating the disaster artist DVD
launch with us make sure to check out
Tommy Wiseau film school on screen
junkies news oh man that was that was I
could watch one of those every week the
different something about Tommy improv
that that are so weirdly charming like
he kind of does always sound like a
tired kid at the store but like at the
same time is so fun to watch him just do
his thing and like in a weird way I'm
wondering if we'll get sick of Tommy
Wiseau soon yeah I feel a lot of Tommy
Wiseau lately the disaster artist his
new movie coming out all the appearances
he's been making I mean this is a really
funny video but I'm getting to a point
as a [ __ ] a tad bit where I'm like okay
maybe we should slow down Tommy Wiseau
train before I get a little bit like oh
you know this is the next Star Wars
influx yeah and to be fair I think best
friends is such that like that movie
looks kind of strange and not silly
enough that I hope it doesn't add to the
blood and I've heard some people and you
never know if you can trust these things
but you know I've heard some people say
that it's actually pretty interesting
I definitely feel you know the meme of
Tommy Wiseau this was a really funny
video that's so cool that he was willing
to stop by work something work out
something with screen junkies to do this
man
the twister was my 58th and they start
off for the best one that was my
favorite one sorry I call you [ __ ]
I love this speech that he's given as a
present in the United States I feel like
these are streams of consciousness like
III every time I see him do something
remotely like this I just wonder further
and further what happens in that man's
head this kind of reminds me of what
makes a disaster artist special is the
love for Tommy Wise oh right because in
light of like those recent events of all
those all that crap that happened with
James Franco and whatnot which kind of
put the disaster artist a little bit in
a kind of a shadow over yeah doing this
kind of stuff does remind you of like oh
this is why the disaster ours is a cool
film this is why it's great yeah and
weirdly I guess for the bigger picture I
suppose it's kind of cool I mean it
really sucks what the you know the James
Franco but it gives the spotlight back
to the dude who started all this yeah
yeah yeah because that's not tarnished
yeah now exactly it's like taught the
weird little gem of Tommy and his
strange film and his his planet his
little world he lives on is still intact
yeah I'm happy about that I'm happy
about that
well thanks screen junkies for doing
this special video man tommy was Oh
Tommy when we gonna get some Greg
Sestero memes memes a great stereo
portrayal something like actual Greg
stare yeah I'll just kind of adopted a
half so yeah he probably wore puka
shells at some point is like well
subscribe to screen junkies if you
haven't already they could use the subs
yeah lord knows they need help from us
for that yeah subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification we'll
get notified every time one of our vids
is up and also make sure to check us out
on beer reviews kampala in the
description box ain't that right Tommy
let's ride ray alright review of you I
see you're a good person you like to
have a good time good do good thing for
people I'd never call you [ __ ]